[Music]
hello everyone
up so today we are going to start a new
chapter on the classical plate theory
so the plan will be exactly the same
as we had followed in our previous
chapter
that is on beam theory so first of all
we are going to
develop a theory for this for this plate
uh and i am going to discuss a bit on
this geometry in a while
so uh just to get back to the plan we
are going to discuss it along the same
line as the beam theory
okay so first of all we are developing
we are going to develop a
theory for this plate uh which
will be simply taking into account on
mostly the bending
but later on we are going to develop a
modified theory uh
completely separately from this chapter
uh and that will be a separate chapter
uh called the bond garment plate theory
where we will be addressing
the buckling of plates so earlier
in the previous chapter what we had uh
in one single chapter both the bending
and the buckling of beams
in this chapter we are going to consider
only the bending of
plates and you will see that
there will be a few uh
few complications as far as the
development of the theory is concerned
but we will we'll rise up to the
challenges and proceed
now regarding the geometry you note that
i have drawn
a fairly general kind of plate here
i have also denoted the thickness by
this h it is such
that this top surface here
is at z is equal to minus h by 2
and this bottom surface that bottom
surface is at
z equal to plus h by 2. because you note
that the z
is pointed downward okay
but very very important to note is that
for this classical plate theory to hold
the theory that we are going to develop
for that to hold this h
must be very very small compared to the
lateral dimensions
of this plate lateral dimensions means
the extents
that this plate has along the x
direction and the y direction so that
h must be much smaller than those
dimensions along the x and y directions
okay uh there will be a few other
simplifying assumptions that we're going
to use
uh but we'll see that as we go along so
just like as in
the bending of beams we are first going
to start out with the kinematical
hypothesis
the spirit is the same and
the only thing that we really have to
worry about here
is taking care of the extra dimension
involved
so back in beam theory we were mostly
dealing with this x
this x direction in the z direction the
bending was taking place in the z
direction
but here additionally we have this extra
dimension y
so that brings in a few more challenges
okay so what we are going to say is that
this u will be described
by this
okay so please note that when i write
this
behind it are the exact same kind of
discussions which are present
uh in the back when we were discussing
beams so i strongly strongly advise you
if you don't remember those or if you
have not seen those
you first go and take a look uh at the
justification behind
these kinds of terms okay how this is uh
how this is emerging
now back in beam theory we had taken
this v the
the the displacement
along the y direction to be 0 but that
is no longer the case
so we will have a stretching variable vs
just like we have a stretching variable
u s along the x direction we have a
stretching variable now
along the y direction and
we also have this term
okay so whatever is happening along the
x direction
a similar kind of thing is happening in
the y direction also okay
now regarding the z direction
it is almost exactly the same as in beam
theory
with the only difference but very
important difference
is that in beam theory the w
the displacement in the z direction was
only a function of
x it was a pure function of x but now
here in classical play theory
this w is a function both of x
and y that is very very important to
note
now these are the
[Music]
the simplifying assumptions regarding
the nature of the displacement that we
start out with
and based on this we should be able to
write down
using the strain displacement relations
the linear strain displacement relations
which we are all familiar with
are to write down the various components
of the strain expressions so
epsilon x x
is del u del x that gives us
these two terms
in a similar fashion epsilon yy
that is del v del y
that gives us del v s del y minus z
del square w del y square
next for epsilon z we have
del w del z and please note that w
being a pure function of x and y not
being dependent on z
this del w del z gives us zero
next for epsilon x y
we have half del u del y
plus del v del x
and that will give us half
del u s del y
looking at this minus z
del square w
[Music]
del y del x
plus half
del vs del x
minus z del square w
del x l y so overall what we are going
to end up with
here
clubbing these two terms together
with the half coefficient in front and
you please note that this term here and
this term here they are
they are the same terms because we don't
care about the
order of the partial derivatives and
what we end up with here is
this thing all right next
for epsilon y z
we have half
del v del z
plus del w
del y now before i proceed any further
i wish to make it absolutely clear that
this u s and this v s here
they are functions of both x and y
okay so please note that us
and vs they are functions
of x and y
okay so just like w is a function of x
and y so also u s
v s otherwise this term this del u s del
y term
would have been zero but it is not so we
keep it
uh uh so
getting back to this epsilon y z what we
are going to
end up with here is that you please note
that since
this v s is a pure function of x and y n
we have v s here
but what we need to do here is this del
v as delta set
and that is going to be zero so
del v s del said
minus again form from this term
only this z is going to be
differentiated out this w
is a pure function of x and y so that
has no business with this
differentiation with respect to z
and we have this
and this del w del y that just gives us
this okay so overall since this is zero
what we have is that this is zero
and finally for epsilon zx
what we are going to have is del w
del x plus del u
del z so in a manner similar to this
epsilon y z what we are going to end up
with here is this
del w del x half that doesn't change
uh from the deluded z term i'll have
del u s del z
minus delta w del x
and that eventually gives me zero right
so you see uh as far as the non-zero
terms are concerned
what i have here is this epsilon xx is
non-zero
epsilon yy is non-zero epsilon x
y is non-zero the other three terms
epsilon z
epsilon y z and epsilon zx are zero
okay so there is a certain
simplification already
emerging out of this kinematical
hypothesis
okay next up
let's see what about the stress terms
because you note that
uh just after this we are going to
utilize the principle of virtual work
uh to write down the various terms
involving the
both the stresses and the strains so
there we need the expressions for the
stresses
let's see what what happens to this
to this stress now first of all you note
what happens
to uh to the case of the sigma zz
because it's a very special thing and a
simplifying assumption will be involved
there
so we are going to use the
linear elastic uh isotropic behavior
or so that kind of material we are going
to use so
we have this we have this
relationship the well-known relationship
from the generalized hooke's law
so already in the previous page we have
seen that this is zero
so what this is giving us
is sigma zz is equal to nu
sigma xx plus sigma yy now in general
the sigma xx and sigma yy
are not going to be zero which means
that this sigma zz
is certainly not going to be zero also
however this is where we uh
so this sigma zz
is not zero okay because
this is not zero this is not zero
in general but this is a very important
part
we forcibly
just to make our life easier we forcibly
assume
we forcibly assume sigma zz
is equal to zero despite what we see
in the above line that is very very
important
okay so this is a very key step in the
development of our theory
there are certain justifications and
there are certain arguments against it
which helps us to uh to go forward and
develop more advanced theories
of course we are not going to go into
those but it is important to understand
that this is a forcible assumption uh
there are certain
justifications there are certain like
very strong arguments against using such
things
uh but anyway we'll proceed and there is
a value to learning this
classical plate theory okay
all right now once we have this
let us go to this expression for epsilon
x x is equal to
this thing
again using the generalized hooke's law
expressions
so now we have assumed the sigma zz is
zero
so this is 1 by e
sigma xx minus nu sigma yy
and in a similar fashion the epsilon yy
that is going to give us
this again sigma zz being 0 what we end
up with here is the sigma yy
minus nu sigma xx so this will be
familiar with everyone who has already
studied
the cases of plane stress and plane
stream now what we want to
uh obtain here is the expressions of
sigma x x and sigma yy
uh in terms of epsilon xx and epsilon yy
and if i do those simplifications okay
if i do those simplifications from what
i get from here
is that sigma xx is equal to
i'm not going to the through the
intermediate steps here
that's this basic algebra
and obtain this for sigma xx and this
for sigma yy
okay so now i am more or less ready with
the key expressions which i need
in order to develop uh the theory
of classical plates using uh or
starting on from the principle of
virtual work so let me
go towards that
now
we proceed
using the principle of virtual work
so just like before
we do not consider the body force terms
which is start out
with this expression
the volume integral on the left and the
area integral on the right
so this is the general thing except that
i have not considered the body force
terms
so uh first of all what i'll do is i'll
consider this left hand side term
and here you please note that uh this is
uh
i mean these kinds of repeated indices
here they they represent the
uh the summation and uh if i if i just
uh
if i just write this out for the
for the case under consideration for the
plate under consideration
uh then this volume integral
that can be written in this fashion so
we have this area integral so that area
integral will be over the
x y domain and i'll also have an
integration with respect to z
and that integration will be from minus
h by 2
to h by 2. because if i just go back a
little bit and
refer to this diagram you please note
that this origin
despite what it may look like it is
actually
placed at the
center surface of this plate it is not
placed this origin is not at the top
surface okay so probably it would have
been better if i had
drawn these uh this y direction and this
x direction this
these two coordinate axis as uh hidden
lines that would have made probably made
the
diagram a bit more clear but anyway this
origin is at the
mid height or the mid surface of this
plate
uh so as i had mentioned the z
this top surface is at z equal to minus
h by 2 the bottom surface is at z equal
to
plus h by 2. okay
now uh when i expand these
this term uh what i will obtain is
sigma xx delta epsilon xx
plus sigma yy delta epsilon yy
plus and here i will obtain two terms so
sigma
xy delta epsilon xy plus sigma yx
delta epsilon yx but we know that they
are the same things
so what we are going to end up with here
is twice of
sigma xy delta
epsilon x y
so the first integration is with respect
to said
and the second integration is over the
entire area uh counting the x y domain
all right uh so what we're going to do
next is to substitute the
uh this this expression
of epsilon xx epsilon yy and epsilon
xy but there will be a little bit of a
temptation
right away to also utilize the
expressions for the sigma xx sigma yy
and the sigma xy
because we have managed to express them
in terms of the epsilon xx and epsilon
yy
but right away we will resist that
temptation and see what what it gives us
okay all right
so proceeding
uh let's take a quick look at the
expression for this epsilon xx
what we have here is this thing and at
the same time let me
take a look at this thing also so uh
once we do the first variation over that
uh what we are going to end up with
is delta partial derivative of the
first variation of this stretching
variable with respect to
x partial with respect to x
minus z del square
delta w del x
square right
i'll separate out the various
integrations
in a similar fashion to the first term i
will have
del delta vs del y
minus z del square delta w
del y squared dz
da and for the last term
i take the twice out of the integrations
let me take a look at the expression of
epsilon x y
the epsilon x y has these things so
what i'm going to do here is to take the
half out
and then i'll have del
delta u s del y
[Music]
plus del delta v s
del x minus twice
of z
del square delta w
del x del y this twice is coming
because uh you can just quickly see
over here that i did not have this twice
here but
here i'm taking the half common over all
the terms so that brings in the twice
okay
all right now you see uh
in each of these terms wherever w is
appearing it is not at all multiplied
so none of these terms this term this
term this term
it is not at all multiplied meaning it
is not at all coupled
with the with either the us or the vs
and that is good news for us in exactly
the same way it was good news for us
back in beam theory
where such kind of
absence of any coupled terms indicated
that physically the stretching and the
bending
were completely decoupled and we had
seen that okay it was as if we were
simultaneously considering two separate
problems
the stretching problem and the bending
problem and here also
because our intention is to address
primarily the bending
so uh and and because we are seeing very
nicely that
the stretching variables and the bending
variables that is the usvs variable
variables are decoupled from the w
variable
therefore what we are going to do is
from now on we are going to concentrate
only on the bending variables okay so
henceforth
we are going to consider only the
bending terms
meaning that we are only going to
consider the terms involving the
w okay so we are going to look at this
term we are going to look at this term
and we are going to look at this term
and you will see that even while uh
making this kind of a simplification
or a or a reduction or reduced uh form
of analysis
we are still going to have to deal with
quite complicated looking terms okay now
let us not forget that in the in the
previous step
uh the sigma xx sigma yy and the sigma
xy had been left
unsubstituted okay so when i say
unsubstituted i mean that i have not
expressed this
in terms of the epsilon xx epsilon yy uh
and this epsilon xy here and uh
certainly
not involving the usvs and the w okay so
do we need to do that right away
answer is no uh we are not going to do
that even now
or rather we are going to do it in a
slightly different fashion
uh which will uh perhaps give us a
better insight
into uh into the mechanics
of the problem okay so what we are going
to say is this
let me go to the new page here uh we are
going to define
a few terms uh it's not something
new to us but it will help us to proceed
okay it will also
reduce uh the
well kind of reduce the amount of uh
amount of writing that would be
otherwise
involved so this mx is the the bending
moment
now that is defined
as minus h by 2 to h by 2
sigma xx z
dz okay so what we are saying here
is uh
if you look back at or or maybe maybe
just look at
a uh
so let me go back to this figure
okay so uh
if you consider a
a cut section like this over here i
don't want to spoil this diagram
if you take a cut section over here then
the kind of figure
that you would be looking at so
if you look at it from the
into the exit plane
it's going to look like this okay our
plate
this jagged line means that there is
more of the plate here which i am not
drawing
this is the
[Music]
x direction this is the
this is the z direction and out of the
plane of the screen
would be our y direction now
at this cut exposed surface this
vertical one
we are going to see a distribution
of sigma z sigma xx
okay so this sigma xx when it is
multiplied
by the z and integrated over the entire
height from minus h by 2 to h by 2.
again note that we are integrating from
the top surface to the bottom surface
in the direction of the positive z so
the entity that we are ending up with as
a result of this integration
is uh is this
mx okay now uh
you can you can probably think of uh
considering some kind of thickness into
it
but it is
i mean our subsequent analysis will be
much easier if we just define it in this
fashion
okay so you think about it in a uh and
it'll it'll strike you and and
and please hold on till we actually go
into the
the simplification or the subsequent
analysis
okay so in a similar fashion we define
this
and we also define this
so i strongly encourage you to try to
interpret these terms especially this
one the sigma x y
the the term involving the sigma x y now
uh if we if we
uh if we go back to the previous step
here
okay and look at it uh here so we have
the sigma xx multiplied by the z
and then we have this integration with
respect to dz so that will give us
the mx term that we have just now
defined similarly the sigma yy
multiplied by the z
integrate with respect to the t z or
with respect to z
that is going to give us the m y term
and finally this sigma
x y multiplied with this z then
integrate over this
right there that is going to give us the
m x y term
okay so uh and we are going to neglect
all this
uh us vs business so uh
if we use this what we are going to end
up with
is the lhs
and when i write the lhs i mean
the lhs covering only the bending terms
and that is going to give me
minus
mx
del square w del x square
d please note
that i have also implicitly used uh
the fact that this term here this del
square delta w del x
square that term is independent
of z okay because this w is a pure
function
of only x and y similarly this term
is uh it's a constant with respect to
this z
so it's independent of z and similarly
this
w and this term here also is independent
of
z so we are taking this term this term
and this term
out of the integration with respect to z
okay
so this is integration over the area
here within this mx is
subsumed the integration with respect to
z in a similar fashion
we'll have
this thing
and then we'll have this mxy term
integration with respect to a uh but let
us not forget
that uh just take a look here that
uh although this half cancels with this
two but we still have a two
outside okay so uh
when we are writing that m x y this 2
has to be taken care of
okay so we have to write this with a 2.
all right now
we are going to make a number of uh
algebraic or we are going to write write
down a number of steps
uh involving some algebraic and calculus
manipulations and we'll do that from the
next video onwards
and i believe it or not uh even though
there will be
a proliferation of terms uh uh it will
be almost hard to keep track of
what is going on but you'll see that at
the end we will be able
to arrive at a step which will enable us
to write down
clearly the governing equations and the
boundary conditions
much in the same way that we have been
doing till now especially quite a number
of times that we have done in the
beam theory so on that note i will end
this video thank you very much